well hello they are watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages
over the next half hour we'll see what's
making the headlines with the consultant
editor of the daily mail andrew pearce
and the associate editor of the daily
mirror kev mcguire
and they will then stay with me after
11. so
welcome to you what a day um let's check
out the front pages
yeah first of all shall we uh the eye
quoting perhaps the most
resting line of dominic cummings
testimony
uh to the house of commons committees
today over the government's handling of
the pandemic
tens of thousands of people died who
didn't need to die
that quote also makes the front page of
the guardian
the metro reacts to his appearance with
the headline dom shell
it is the same headline for the daily
mail but with rather more details
including his assertion
that the health secretary matt hancock
should have been fired 15 to 20 times in
the early days of the outbreak
the times declares cummings rains fire
on
number 10. the financial times focuses
on mr cummings allegation that mr
johnson was
unfit to lead the country during a
pandemic
well the telegraph shows him talking in
animated fashion
during his appearance cummings takes
revenge
they say so plenty to discuss as you can
imagine andrew pierce kevin mcguire
are here we will come on to the
credibility or otherwise of this witness
but first of all the accusation andrew
lions led by donkeys including
the man at the top who is quite simply
unfit for office um
what did you make of it well this was
probably the most remarkable political
theater i've ever witnessed um i was in
the commons when
jeffrey howe made that resignation
speech which
setting trained the a series of events
that toppled margaret thatcher
and that was highly charged remarkable
because of what what flowed from it but
in terms of sheer um theater
coming speaking for seven hours and
seven minutes
um raining allegations down on just
about everybody who he's ever worked
with in number 10
was remarkable and you've got to take a
lot of what he says
seriously because it's the first time
we've heard from somebody
inside number 10 in public willing to
give
um what he would regard as an insider's
view of what went wrong now look we can
argue about
the veracity of what he said his
motivation
but some of it had the ring of truth to
it uh
we know that there was a there was
chaotic plans in place for ppe
uh we know that the prime minister took
us late into the lockdown
what we didn't know was that he was
willing at one point if it's true
for chris whittie to inject him with
some covid
uh uh virus so we people could show it's
no worse than
the flu or swine flu extraordinary and
then the extraordinary stuff from the
cabinet secretary
who said we could just have chickenpox
parties i mean it was
it was really really peculiar what was
going on in number 10
clearly they weren't prepared for it but
then i would argue that was probably the
same in a lot of governments around the
world and europe
but it makes for a pretty chilling
picture
of what was happening in number 10 at
the time if as i say
cummings is telling the truth and that's
a big if yes political drama
no doubt about it kevin but it was also
a hard watch because you want to believe
you have a fully functioning competent
government
who has planned for the best outcomes
and is watching the world
to learn what they do and it was laid
bare tonight or today
that that didn't exist in march last
year
no well beyond march actually it wasn't
just uh
just then anna and i think political
satire was killed
today at dominic cummings account
remember
he's only been out for about six months
and he and boris johnson were incredibly
close they
were brothers in arms on brexit uh
cummings came up with the dead brexit
done slogan for the 2019 election was
lauded by the prime minister they have
fallen out but you just look there's the
daily mail back the tories at the last
general election wanted boris johnson to
be
prime minister but any any journalist
anyone objective
uh watching and listening to that would
be
absolutely horrified at what went
uh uh went on and i think i think there
was a ring of authenticity
about much of it if it had been reading
the newspapers you would have
been aware of a lot of this watching tv
and radio perhaps not the express and
newspapers but all the other newspapers
have been
having a flavor and details of this all
along and then you get somebody
who was there which what is why he has
to be taken
seriously that's not to say everything
he he said
may turn out to be accurate some of it
will be his own
interpretation but it was just
incredible it just kept on coming and
often these events
don't live up to the billing but this
exceeded it
in far far far spades beyond that and
look i remember the the resignation
speeches of geoffrey howes mentioned by
andrew
uh norman lamont uh robin coop they're
all big moments
they were they were exceeded by this i
thought um
rupert murdoch's humbling up the culture
committee
some years ago was a big moment that was
far exceeded here
and it matters because as the guardian
picked out and i think the eye picked
out
he says tens of thousands of people died
needlessly that will be
families mourning lost loved ones who
didn't
need to die that is the most serious
accusation you could
level at any prime minister any health
secretary
any government at all that is what it's
about that is why
it matters and it really just matters in
spades
johnson's got away with so much in the
past i wonder
uh it'd be rushed to predict this but i
do wonder
if this might be a turning point in his
his public standing because he took such
a back route
probably not as big a bat ring as matt
hancock the uh the health secretary
when the cabinet secretary is said to
have wanted to to get shot with me says
he
15 to 20 reasons he should have been
kicked out and he was lying
well we know he lied about care homes
and he said a protective ring was thrown
around
care homes because they they weren't
patients were just starched from
hospital who were infected and they
weren't tested and they were put into
accounts but according to cummings
hancock had told the prime minister
before the prime minister himself went
in hospital
that they would be tested and then they
won't be tested
and this is why i suppose cummings
accuses him
of a criminality and wouldn't rule out
corporate manslaughter charges
yes and we will have or that those
committees will have
their right to reply from matt hancock
on the 10th of june
he will also appear we're told on
thursday both in the commons
an urgent labor question and at a press
conference so he's clearly
coming out fighting but what about the
the crucial questions about the prime
minister
almost painted as an absent figure by
dominic cummings today andrew
first of all a non-believer as you said
from the start you know
it's swine flu don't go to cobra he'll
just tell people it's swine flu and not
to worry about it
you know absent and then on holiday in
february having delivered brexit which
presumably was the great celebratory
moment
and then ill and in hospital i mean not
to mention
later on in the year um with his
thoughts on
on another lockdown yeah look
if it's true it's it's and how will we
ever know there is through
we must remember there'll be an official
inquiry next year and it will be
done in front of a judge and it'll be
done on oath and
evidence will have to be provided it was
quite conspicuous that cummings talked
about oh i do have whatsapp messages i
do have texts but
there was no documentary evidence
whatsoever today
that's not to sub to detract however
from the fact that
clearly in february when the prime
minister missed five cobra meetings
there well there was a suggestion
somewhere the other day
he was writing a book about shakespeare
i think that may have been disproved now
that idea
but um what was he doing was he was he
actually fixing his divorce from his
wife marina
uh if the worry i think as well about
this anna
clearly the sage committee of scientists
were giving
pretty poor advice because if the prime
minister thought this was no worse than
swine flu
where was he getting his information
from the sage committee
they were very slow they were apparently
warning him
a lockdown wasn't necessary so what was
going on with those sage scientists the
minutes
of those meetings that we've rarely seen
in those early days and weeks
there was a real problem we also know
that public health england
was a failing organization and it's
being wound up and got rid of
but it seems that just about everybody
every organization
that should have been involved in this
if you believe cummings
was not fit for purpose and was not
delivering i know but that that's the
really crucial question here isn't it
how did they all
not know that is the allegation when the
public did it was hard to buy lu roll
at the start of march i mean the public
knew what was coming
so it kind of becko's belief that all of
those really super brainy
people didn't actually work it out kevin
yeah well the public were watching uh tv
news and seen what was uh happening in
italy they were reading the newspapers
they
they were aware and they were ahead of
the game and
boris johnson he always likes to lead
well what does he do he
sees where a crowd is going and then he
runs to the front pretends he's leading
it he was behind
on this and what was really quite
alarming
is he's even more slapdash
and careless and just treats events as a
joke when they're really serious then we
we thought and i understand now anna
why he doesn't want a public inquiry to
report before the next general election
because we got a flavor today of what
would come out and what would be
said and i'm sure some of what cummings
said would be supported by others you
would have
on oath then cabinet secretary mark said
well he's going to have to account for
chickenpox
parties but certainly on hancock if he
wanted him gone
why did he want him to go and it would
be incredibly
embarrassing for the prime minister and
his cabinet and the conservative party
if this all comes out in greater depth
and more detail from more people before
a general election because going back to
the headlines
in the guardian and the eye this is
about people
dying and tens of thousands of people
dying
needlessly is incredible charge
to level against a prime minister and a
health secretary
and a government and a party it does not
get any more serious than this
but you know cummings himself isn't a
very sympathetic character there's a you
gov poll
showing 55 percent of people don't trust
the prime minister to tell the truth
uncovered but 75
didn't trust dominic cummings because
of that barnard castle county durham uh
journey which he kind of changed his
tune a bit
on it today but other stuff just
had the ring of being true
i would like i'd like to see detailed
long-term interviews with hancock and
johnson
where they are scrutinized and you know
you know certainly the prime minister
dodges those detailed interviews as much
as he can
what he likes is a little clip for the
news a little comment a one quote
and then off he goes he gives the
impression that he's very available to
the public
and he's engaging and he'll answer
anything but he doesn't do it in
any detailed way he flies by
the seat of his pants pants which lie a
liar pants on
on fire he is he is in trouble i think
with the public now on this
it doesn't mean it's gonna be gone but i
just think
people people will want him held to
account
and they won't be given him the benefit
the doubt that he's enjoyed in the past
in the same way well i i'm not i'm not
so sure that he is in big political
trouble actually um
because that because this is one man's
word
he's bitter and twisted he was sacked
from his job he's bitterly resentful
because
uh he thinks boris johnson owes him
everything it was boris
it was cummings clever campaigning that
helped win the brexit referendum
against all the odds it was cummings who
took him into that election in december
2019
and again get the slogan get brexit done
it was coming to recognize
that the red wall was vulnerable years
and years of
neglect labor is the establishment there
he thought that that was a way to
win the general election winning big so
he feels bitterly
bitterly betrayed and let down by boris
johnson and that will
inevitably inevitably color much of what
he says so
of course a lot of what he says may be
factual but a lot of what he says may be
exaggerated
and designed as the telegraph puts on
his front page
to wreak revenge he wanted revenge and
by god he got it yes and we'll certainly
talk more about that as well
um that very question on the front page
of the telegraph did dominic cummings
only want revenge if so did he get it
that and more after this break
well welcome back to watching the press
preview with me andrew pierce kevin
mcguire so much to talk about let's
return to cummings
on the front page of the telegraph which
raises this question uh kevin that this
was all about revenge
um we should mention too the idea of him
as a as a credible witness we've known
he's never really liked the system
or politicians he's been famously rude
about them in the in the past
did he come up across do you think he's
a control freak he came back from
being ill with covid and hancock had
dared to dictate policy in his absence
and
set targets for testing and he he didn't
like it i mean
will these politicians be saved because
of his have the questions about his
credibility as a witness
uh possibly anna yes i'll go back to the
2016
uh brexit campaign when he put that 350
million pound
a week for the nhs lie down a bus he
said that was pivotal in winning the
referendum and it was a an outright lie
he wasn't
he wasn't uh truthful about breaking the
corbett rules in county durham
and barnard castle um no i mean bloke is
an
eagle century uh he's a bit mad
really isn't he uh it's all about him he
thought rules didn't apply to him he
could do whatever he he wanted
but i think as curious thomas said the
problem for the prime minister is he's
got to decide
whether he was lie he was lying and he's
going to say
dominic cummings was lying then boris
johnson's got to answer well why did you
put him right at the heart of downing
street for
so long and according to cummings you
could just pop in and out
of the pride the prime minister's uh
room but you're quite right that the
government will target him and they will
they will have
good reason to some extent to target him
uh i'm somebody who's accused him of
lying before they believe everything
he says now but yes revenge
may be part of it but also curiously
people
sometimes are more honest when they're
out of office and want to put the record
straight and want their
their version of the truth it may not be
the full truth
but it's a version of the truth